OK, here's a simple way to measure how violent things have gotten in Iraq. Calling around this week to five English-speaking Iraqis. Every one of them knew somebody who's died in the violence since the US invasion. A doctor in Baghdad, who's active in politics, told me he knows over 300 people who've died. A guy in Babylon says it's pretty safe where he lives, but his cousin was shot by Americans when he got too close to them on the road. A medical student's cousins died from an IED exploding in the street. And he has friends who died too.
好的，这有一个衡量伊拉克暴力程度变得有多严重的方法。这周我联系了五位说英语的伊拉克人，他们每个人都认识死于这场入侵以来暴力事件的人。巴格达的一位医生，在政治上很活跃，告诉我他认识的人中已经有超过300人死亡。巴比伦的一名男子说他住的地方很安全，但他表弟在路上离美国人太近时被枪杀了。一名医学院学生的堂兄弟死于街头的简易爆炸装置（IED），他还有其他朋友也死了。
One of them was kidnapped. Then the cops were trying to save them, then accidentally he was shot. Then another friend that I had in college, he was in my grade-- it was last year-- he was in his car, driving to college, and he was suddenly shot by unknown men.
其中一人被绑架了。后来警察试图营救，结果他意外中弹身亡。还有我在大学时的一位朋友，和我同年级，就在去年，他开车去上大学时突然被不明身份的人枪杀。
Just today told me, when he went to the store near his house, he saw three people were killed. No one knows why. Ali, a bookstore owner in Baghdad that I talked to picked up a list of people he knows who've died. Friends, relatives neighbors.
就在今天，他告诉我当他去家附近的商店时，看到三个人被杀，没人知道原因。我采访过的一位巴格达书店老板阿里，列出了一份他认识的死者名单，包括朋友、亲戚和邻居。
The situation, no matter how much I don't talk about, it cannot described how it is.
无论我怎么说，现在的局势都无法用言语来形容。
How often will you hear that a friend or a friend of a friend or a relative has died? Is it once a week?
你多久会听到一次朋友、朋友的朋友或亲戚死亡的消息？是一周一次吗？
Every day, believe me.
相信我，每天都有。
No. Every day?
不，每天？
I swear. Just two hours ago a neighbor has been killed in our neighborhood. He was shot dead.
我发誓。就在两小时前，我们社区的一位邻居被杀了，他被枪杀了。
Shot dead. How, why, where was he?
被枪杀了？怎么、为什么、他在哪里？
He was with his wife in his car, and some gunmen pulled over and just shot him and gunned him down because he's a Shiite.
他当时和妻子在车里，一些枪手把车靠边停下，直接把他开枪打死了，因为他是什叶派。
That's horrible.
太可怕了。
I saw three similar incidents-- getting a man killed in front of his wife and two children. The oldest girl is about five years of age. And she was shouting, oh, daddy, please daddy, don't die. In front of my eyes. I don't know these people, but this happened in front of my eyes.
我目睹过三起类似的事件——一个人当着他妻子和两个孩子的面被杀。最大的女孩大约五岁，她在尖叫：“噢，爸爸，求求你爸爸，不要死。”就在我眼前。我不认识这些人，但这事就发生在我眼前。
It's like you're getting used to it. You hear people die. OK, people die.
感觉就像你已经习惯了。你听说有人死了，好吧，有人死了。
It's at the point now where if you go up to a dead body and try to clear it away, you're in danger of getting shot yourself. It's at the point now where Iraqis are getting their names, addresses, and phone numbers tattooed on their bodies. So if they're killed, their bodies will be identified and returned to their families.
现在已经到了这种地步：如果你走近一具尸体并试图清理它，你自己就有被枪杀的危险。现在伊拉克人甚至把他们的名字、地址和电话号码纹在身上，这样如果他们被杀，尸体就能被确认身份并归还给家人。
People I talked to said they're scared all the time. Everybody said that it was better when Saddam was in power. Not that they like Saddam. Mohaned, an architect, described the choice between Saddam and the current situation in this way.
我交谈过的人都说他们一直生活在恐惧中。每个人都说萨达姆执政时更好。并不是说他们喜欢萨达姆。莫哈内德，一位建筑师，这样描述在萨达姆和当前局势之间的选择。
They're two bad choices, I must say. Saddam's staying in power is not a solution.
我必须说，这是两个糟糕的选择。萨达姆继续执政并不是解决办法。
Yeah.
是的。
And there was no light at the end of the tunnel, so to speak. But today there is no tunnel.
可以这么说，隧道尽头没有光。但今天，甚至连隧道都没有了。
Seems like every day we hear these stories and numbers from Iraq. Car bombings, more deaths, sectarian killings. But today on our radio show, we try to understand what you would think would be one of the simplest facts about the war, once and for all.
似乎每天我们都会从伊拉克听到这些故事和数字。汽车炸弹、更多的死亡、教派杀戮。但今天在我们的广播节目中，我们试图彻底弄清楚关于这场战争最简单的事实之一。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our program in three acts today. Now, in the second half of the show we have a very unusual recording of US forces trying to make things right with Iraqis, after the US accidentally killed 12 civilians. In the other acts of the show we talk about a number, and in one of the acts a small news story that nobody ever really seemed to take very seriously at the time. And what was really behind that story. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为三幕。在下半场，我们将播放一段非常罕见的录音，内容是美军在意外杀害12名平民后，试图与伊拉克人修复关系。在节目的其他环节中，我们将谈论一个数字，以及一段当时似乎没人太当回事的小新闻，以及那个故事背后的真相。请继续收听。
Act One. Truths, Damn Truths, and Statistics. Well, the number that we're going to talk about right now-- and we are going to talk about a number-- the number is how many civilians have died as a result of a war. Fact is, nobody is even pretending to have an accurate count. Iraqi Ministry of Health for a while, early on in the war, was compiling morgue figures from across the country and making them public each week. But that practice was stopped. There's also a privately run nonprofit web site called iraqbodycount.net, which keeps a running tally of confirmed deaths in Iraq. That's as opposed to an estimate of all the deaths in the country.
第一幕。真相、该死的真相和统计数据。嗯，我们要讨论的数字——我们确实要讨论一个数字——就是这场战争导致了多少平民死亡。事实上，没人敢说自己有准确的统计数据。战争初期，伊拉克卫生部曾一度汇总全国的停尸房数据并每周公布，但后来停止了。还有一个名为iraqbodycount.net的私营非营利网站，它会对伊拉克的确认死亡人数进行实时统计，这不同于对全国所有死亡人数的估计。
And there have been two studies published in the British medical journal, The Lancet . One of the studies came out just a few weeks ago. The other came out two years ago. And both of these studies arrived at casualty numbers that are so high, they shocked many people.
英国医学杂志《柳叶刀》上发表过两项研究。其中一项是几周前发表的，另一项是两年前发表的。这两项研究得出的伤亡数字之高，震惊了许多人。
Right now, in this first act, we're going to return to a story that one of our producers, Alex Blumberg, did for our show a year ago about that first Lancet study. Later in the show, in act three, we're going to look at the study that just came out. Anyway, here's Alex.
现在，在第一幕中，我们将回顾我们的一位制片人亚历克斯·布伦伯格一年前为我们节目制作的关于第一项《柳叶刀》研究的故事。稍后在第三幕中，我们将审视刚刚发布的研究。不管怎样，这是亚历克斯的报道。
Everyone will tell you counting casualties in wartime is hard. First of all, you need to do something called a large-scale mortality survey. And second of all, you need to do it in the middle of a war zone.
每个人都会告诉你，在战时统计伤亡人数很困难。首先，你需要进行所谓的“大规模死亡率调查”；其次，你需要在战区内完成它。
The first attempt ever made in Iraq was this Johns Hopkins University study published in The Lancet , a British Medical Journal, in late October 2004. A couple of days before the US presidential election. It concluded that probably a 100,000 Iraqis died as a result of the war. This figure was astonishingly high. 10 times higher than any other casualty estimates at the time.
伊拉克历史上首次此类尝试是约翰霍普金斯大学的研究，该研究于2004年10月下旬，即美国总统大选前几天发表在英国医学杂志《柳叶刀》上。研究结论是：因战争导致的伊拉克人死亡人数可能达到10万人。这个数字高得惊人，是当时任何其他伤亡估计的10倍。
Because of this, and because the study itself got almost no traction in the press, I remember thinking at the time it came out that it was probably bogus and slanted. I'm guessing a lot of people, if they heard about the study at all, felt the way I did.
正因为如此，也因为这项研究在媒体上几乎没有引起关注，我记得当时它发布时，我以为它可能是假的，有偏见的。我猜很多人即使听说过这项研究，也是这么想的。
But recently, in trying to find out how many Iraqis have died in the war, I've learned more about the Lancet study. And the more I learned about it, and the remarkable story of how it was done, the more likely it seems that the 100,000 figure is actually the best estimate and possibly low.
但最近，在试图弄清战争中到底有多少伊拉克人死亡时，我了解了更多关于《柳叶刀》研究的情况。我了解得越多，以及了解这项研究如何进行的非凡故事后，我就越觉得10万这个数字实际上是最好的估计，甚至可能还是偏低的。
Before the Iraq study, the main thing I was known for-- and that I'd testified in front of Congress for-- was documenting how many people had died in the war in the Congo.
在伊拉克研究之前，我最著名的工作——以及我曾为此在国会作证的工作——是记录刚果战争中有多少人死亡。
This is Les Roberts, the lead author on the Lancet study. And one of a handful of scientists in the world who could be called an expert in counting war dead.
这是莱斯·罗伯茨，《柳叶刀》研究的主要作者，也是世界上少数几位可以被称为“战争死亡统计专家”的科学家之一。
In the Congo study he found that 1.7 million civilians had died from the war, a figure cited by Colin Powell when he was Secretary of State and Tony Blair on the floor of the British Parliament. Les has also done studies in Burundi, Rwanda and Sierra Leone.
在刚果的研究中，他发现有170万平民死于战争，科林·鲍威尔担任国务卿时和托尼·布莱尔在英国议会发言时都引用过这个数字。莱斯还在布隆迪、卢旺达和塞拉利昂进行过研究。
To a guy in Les Robert's line of work, the war in Iraq had a number of unique and interesting things that deserve study. The main thing that distinguished this war was that the military took unprecedented care to avoid civilian casualties. Almost 2/3 of the bombs dropped were precision guided, as compared to just 8% in the first Gulf War and 0% in World War II. They limited daytime strikes and avoided civilian infrastructure like power and sewer plants. Compare that to World War II, where American forces firebombed entire cities as part of the military strategy, killing up to 100,000 people in Tokyo alone. And upwards of half a million civilians in Europe.
对于像莱斯·罗伯茨这一行的人来说，伊拉克战争有许多值得研究的独特且有趣的地方。这场战争的主要区别在于，军方采取了前所未有的措施来避免平民伤亡。投放的炸弹中近三分之二是有精确制导的，相比之下，第一次海湾战争中只有8%，二战中为0%。他们限制了白天空袭，并避开了电力和污水处理厂等平民基础设施。将其与二战相比，当时美军作为军事战略的一部分轰炸了整个城市，仅在东京就造成多达10万人死亡，在欧洲造成超过50万平民死亡。
And you can see why George Bush called the Iraq War one of the most quote, "humane military campaigns in history." The lesson here that often it's not bombs and bullets that kill people in war, it's the other things that happen when society falls apart. Clean water and medical supplies get scarce. In a lot of the studies he did in Africa, diarrhea killed more people than weapons did. Women can't get to the hospital to deliver their babies so infant mortality rates go up as well.
你可以明白为什么乔治·布什称伊拉克战争是“历史上最人道的军事行动之一”。这里的教训是，战争中杀人的往往不是炸弹和子弹，而是社会崩溃时发生的其他事情。清洁水和医疗用品变得短缺。在他做的很多非洲研究中，腹泻杀的人比武器还多。妇女无法去医院分娩，婴儿死亡率也会上升。
It took Les a long time to get to Iraq and see if the same things were happening there. First, an Iraqi doctor who he'd planned to work with, died in an auto accident. Another social ill, by the way, that tends to increase during wartime. And then insurgent violence spiked.
莱斯花了很长时间才到达伊拉克观察那里是否发生了同样的事情。首先，他计划合作的一位伊拉克医生死于车祸——顺便说一下，这也是战时容易增加的社会弊病之一。然后叛乱暴力激增。
It wasn't until August of 2004, five months after he'd originally planned to go, that he finally landed in Amman, Jordan. He had $24,000 in foundation money in his pocket, his passport, and a letter of invitation from the Iraqi Ministry of Education. He found a driver, a retired Iraqi army officer named Wahid, who agreed to take him to Baghdad. Problems started at the very first checkpoint, on the border between Jordan and Iraq.
直到2004年8月，也就是他原计划出发5个月后，他才终于抵达约旦安曼。他口袋里有2.4万美元的基金会资金、他的护照和一封来自伊拉克教育部的工作邀请信。他找了一位名叫瓦希德的退休伊拉克军官做司机，同意带他去巴格达。问题从约旦和伊拉克边境的第一个检查站就开始了。
Well, he takes my passport, he takes my letter of invitation, and he goes and he comes out just a few minutes later and he is just terrified. Turns out he bumped into a former friend of his from his military days, and he had pulled out my passport in front of him. And his friend just blanched and pushed the passport back into his pocket and said, "You have an American here. Are you crazy? Don't let anyone see that. Just get the hell out of here and don't let me see you again. And oh, you idiot."
他拿走我的护照，拿走邀请信，几分钟后出来时显得非常恐惧。原来他撞见了一个以前军队时期的老朋友，而他当着朋友的面拿出了我的护照。他的朋友脸色惨白，把护照塞回他口袋里说：“你带了个美国人来？你疯了吗？别让任何人看到。赶紧滚，别再让我见到你。你这个白痴。”
Fortunately for Les, Wahid he was something of a Han Solo figure. An unenthusiastic but talented smuggler, who didn't look for trouble but didn't run away from it once it found him. He talked his way through that first checkpoint.
幸运的是，莱斯遇到的瓦希德有点像韩·索罗。一个虽然不情愿但技术高超的走私者，他不找麻烦，但麻烦找上门时也不会逃跑。他通过交涉通过了第一个检查站。
And we drive up a couple of miles. And he pulls off the road, behind this abandoned old gas station. And in the upholstery of his car, he's got hidden another pair of license plates with a different color. And he's got another registration form to go with those license plates.
我们开了几英里。他把车停在路边，那是一个被遗弃的老旧加油站后面。在车的装饰衬垫里，他藏了另一副不同颜色的车牌，还有一份与车牌相符的行驶证。
So quickly, he gets out and he changes his license plates. And he says, "Look, you must lie down. You must stay hidden." And so I spent the next eight hours lying on the floor. And we actually had to go through two extra points where they stopped and looked around in the car. And he chatted with folks and here I am, I'm lying down behind the back seat on the floor.
他迅速下车换了车牌，对我说：“听着，你必须躺下，必须躲起来。”于是接下来的8个小时我一直躺在地板上。我们实际上又经过了两个额外检查点，他们拦下车并四处查看。他在和人闲聊，而我当时就蜷缩在后座地板上。
So when they stopped and looked around, you were actually hiding from them?
所以当他们拦截并环顾四周时，你实际上是在躲着他们？
That's right.
没错。
And were you scared?
你害怕吗？
That's a funny thing. I had consciously made the decision that it was worth trading my life for a chance at getting a realistic estimate of how many Iraqi civilians have died and how they've died. So I was quite at peace with the notion of dying when I went.
这是件奇怪的事。我当时已经清醒地做出了决定，为了有机会获得对伊拉克平民死亡人数和死因的真实估计，即使付出生命也是值得的。所以我出发时对于死亡的概念感到非常平静。
Les finally made it to Baghdad, where he met, for the first time in person, his Iraqi co-researcher. The man with whom he'd be working for the next month. His name was Riyadh Lafta, and he was a doctor of community medicine at Al-Mustansiriya University, in Baghdad. Riyadh had hired a team of researchers, mostly doctors from his university. All of them native Iraqis, but fluent in English.
莱斯终于到了巴格达，在那里他第一次见到了他的伊拉克合作研究员——他接下来一个月将与之共事的人。他的名字叫利雅得·拉夫塔，是巴格达穆斯坦西里亚大学的社区医学博士。利雅得雇佣了一个研究团队，大部分是来自他大学的医生。他们都是伊拉克本地人，但英语流利。
Let's pause here a moment to talk about their methodology. Because when the study came out later, a lot of people wanted to believe that it was flawed or biased. In fact, the survey team used a standard methodology for measuring health and mortality over a geographic area. It's called a cluster sample survey, and it works like this.
让我们在这里暂停一下，谈谈他们的方法论。因为后来这项研究发表时，很多人想当然地认为它是有缺陷或有偏见的。事实上，调查小组使用了测量地理区域健康和死亡率的标准方法，即“聚类抽样调查”，它是这样工作的：
Using the most recent census figures available on Iraq, the team made what was essentially a map of the population. They then used a random number generator to pick 33 points on that map. Baghdad was the biggest population center, so it got several points by itself. But the other points were spread all over the country, from the Kurdish north to the Shiite south. From small towns to big cities.
利用伊拉克最近的人口普查数据，研究小组绘制了一份人口地图。然后他们使用随机数生成器在地图上挑选了33个点。巴格达是最大的中心，所以它本身就占了几个点，但其他点分布在全国各地，从库尔德人的北部到什叶派的南部，从城镇到大城市。
Once they picked a town though, the team still had to figure out who the interview there. Here again, they worked hard to leave everything to chance. Using GPS units, they would drive around the outskirts of the town and store the coordinates, creating a rough outline of the town border. They would then generate a random point within that border, drive to it, and interview the 30 nearest households. It was such a commitment to random sampling that the first few times the team did it, even the researchers Les and Riyadh were working with found it obsessive.
一旦选定了一个城镇，团队仍需要确定去采访谁。在这里，他们同样努力让一切交给偶然。利用GPS设备，他们会在城镇郊区开车，存储坐标，勾勒出城镇边界的大致轮廓。然后，他们在边界内生成一个随机点，驱车前往，并采访离该点最近的30户人家。这种对随机抽样的执着，甚至连与莱斯和利雅得一起工作的研究人员最初都觉得太痴迷了。
It was very annoying to them, because here they are in the car. they're out there feeling like they're at risk. And they'd be driving around for a long time to get to the extremes of the city and draw their map before they interviewed the first house. They're driving around and not getting any work done, they felt.
这让他们感到非常烦恼，因为他们坐在车里，感觉自己身处险境，却为了采访第一户人家之前还要花很长时间绕着城市跑，画出地图。他们觉得一直在开车，却没做成什么正事。
And this is all just to make it as scientifically valid as possible, right?
这都是为了让它尽可能科学有效，对吧？
This is a way of picking houses without any sort of preference for safe neighborhoods, dangerous neighborhoods, near the highway, far from the highway. It was a way of sort of transcending human laziness so that, in essence, every household in Iraq had an equal chance we would visit them. And that is, in essence, the definition of random.
这是一种选择房屋的方法，没有任何对安全街区、危险街区、靠近公路或远离公路的偏好。这是一种超越人类懒惰的方式，本质上让伊拉克的每一户人家都有平等的被访问机会，这本质上就是“随机”的定义。
The survey went smoothly, at least for the first couple of days. People, it turned out, were much more willing to answer questions, even to provide death certificates as verification, than the researchers had initially thought they'd be. In fact, the trouble, when it came, came from Les himself.
调查进展顺利，至少头几天是这样。事实证明，人们回答问题的意愿比研究人员最初预想的要高得多，甚至愿意提供死亡证明作为验证。事实上，麻烦出现时，是因为莱斯本人。
Must be about the fifth day I was out with them, the eighth cluster I attended. I and two of the interviewers were up in a town to the north called Balad. And there was a huge picture of the cleric Sadr as he rolled in to Balad. So clearly it was an anti-coalition city in a big way.
大概是我和他们一起工作的第五天，我参加的第八个聚类调查。我和两名访谈员在北方一个叫巴拉德的城镇。车队驶入巴拉德时，到处都是宗教人士萨德尔的巨大画像。显然，这是一个极其反联军的城市。
Sadr of Sadr militia.
萨德尔民兵组织的？
Of the Sadr militia. That's right. And as fate would have it, the first or second door they knocked on was the governor's house. And so somebody calls the police.
萨德尔民兵组织的。没错。正如命运所安排的那样，他们敲开的第一或第二扇门竟然是省长的家，于是有人报了警。
Les watched from the car as the police took the two researchers, both doctors. One a dignified man in his fifties and the other a single mother, and drove them away. He was terrified that somehow the police would find out that they were working with him, an American. But he could do nothing but sit in the parked car and hope no one discovered him.
莱斯在车里看着警察带走了那两名研究员，他们都是医生。一位是50多岁尊严感十足的男士，另一位是单亲妈妈。他非常害怕警察会查出他们在和一个美国人工作。但他无能为力，只能坐在停着的车里，祈祷没人发现他。
I had done everything I could to be invisible. I wore boring Iraqi clothing. I had dyed my hair black. I had grown a beard so I would look right, but it still didn't look right. They had made up a fake business cards that said Doctor Abdul Salaam, that I was from Bosnia. Because that would explain me being a blue-eyed, non-Arabic speaking, but I could still be a Muslim and that would make me OK.
我已经尽我所能让自己隐形。我穿着单调的伊拉克服装，把头发染成了黑色，留了胡子，好让自己看起来正常点，但看起来还是不像。他们还伪造了名片，说我是阿卜杜勒·萨拉姆医生，来自波斯尼亚。因为那样可以解释为什么我蓝眼睛、不会说阿拉伯语，但仍然可以是穆斯林，那样我就没事了。
And I was just so worried that sitting there for an exorbitant length of time would draw attention, that I put the back of the passenger seat down and I sort of laid on my side to pretend I was asleep. So I wouldn't have to speak to anyone if anyone came to the window of the car. And I had probably been lying on my side for about 20, 30 minutes.
我非常担心坐在那里太久会引起注意，所以我就把副驾驶座靠背放平，侧身躺着假装睡觉，这样如果有人来到车窗前，我就不用说话了。我大概侧身躺了20、30分钟。
And these two little kids, they might have been 10, they came up to the window beside where I was. They stuck their head in the car, they looked around-- and I'm pretending to be asleep-- and they said to me in English, hello mister! And even with my eyes closed, pretending to be asleep, there's just no way I could pretend I was an Iraqi. And there was no way around it. So that was a pretty just horrifying experience all around.
结果两个小孩子——大概10岁左右——走到我旁边的窗户前。他们把头伸进车里，四处看了看——我还在假装睡觉——他们用英语对我说：“你好，先生！”即使闭着眼睛装睡，我也没法假装成伊拉克人。这无可奈何，那是一次非常恐怖的经历。
And I'm wondering, have I gotten these two lovely interviewers arrested or killed. And after an hour or a little more, a car brought back the two interviewers. And they went right back to work. They didn't come to the car. They didn't look at us. They didn't acknowledge us. They just went right back to work and finished out the 30 houses randomly picked in that neighborhood, and off we went.
我心想，我是不是害得这两位可爱的访谈员被捕或被杀了？一个多小时后，一辆车把他们送了回来。他们直接回去工作了。他们没来车边，没看我们，没理会我们，只是直接回去工作，完成了该街区随机挑选的30户人家，然后我们就离开了。
But after that day, no interviewer ever spoke to me again. Not in person.
但从那天起，再也没有研究员跟我说过话，当面也没说过。
Riyadh and Les decided that for everyone's safety he should lay as low as possible. So for the next 16 days straight he didn't leave his hotel. To pass the time, he crunched the numbers that the survey teams were calling in to him every night.
利雅得和莱斯决定，为了每个人的安全，他应该尽可能低调。于是接下来的16天里，他足不出户。为了打发时间，他计算着调查小组每天晚上打回来的数据。
The surveyors were getting basically two pieces of information from each household. How many people in that household had died in the 14 months before the invasion. And of what and when. And how many had died in the 17 months after the invasion. And of what and when.
调查员从每户人家基本上获取两类信息：入侵前14个月家里有多少人去世，死因和时间；以及入侵后17个月里有多少人去世，死因和时间。
By the time the teams had completed their 32nd out of 33 clusters, over 900 households and over 7,000 people, the results were pretty shocking. The death rate itself had gone up about 60%. A large increase, but one that Les had expected from his other surveys. The shocker was how people were dying. For the first time, in any of his surveys, the leading cause of death wasn't disease. It was bombs and bullets.
当团队完成33个聚类中的32个，采访了900多户人家、7000多人时，结果非常令人震惊。死亡率本身上升了约60%。这虽是很大幅度的增长，但也是莱斯根据其他调查预料到的。真正令人震惊的是死因。在他的任何调查中，这还是第一次，主要的死亡原因不是疾病，而是炸弹和子弹。
In the 32 of the 33 clusters sampled, 21 people died of violence. That's compared to just one violent death in the period before the war. Of those 21, two people died in firefights where it was unclear where the bullet came from. Three were killed by insurgents, or Saddam loyalists. Seven died from criminal violence-- carjackings, revenge killings, that sort of thing. And the biggest number, nine, were killed by the American-led coalition.
在抽样的32个聚类中，有21人死于暴力。相比之下，战前同期仅有一例暴力死亡。在这21人中，两人死于枪战，无法确定子弹来源；三人被叛乱分子或萨达姆拥护者杀害；七人死于犯罪暴力——劫车、复仇杀人等；人数最多的一类——九人，死于美国领导的联军之手。
I should mention that only three of them involved guys with guns. All the rest were helicopter gunships, and bombs from planes. So it's not about individual soldiers doing bad things. In fact, two of those three cases, when soldiers shot civilians with their guns, they actually went to the houses of the decedents and apologized to the families. So there's no evidence here of soldiers running amok. There's evidence here of a style of engagement that probably has relied very heavily on air power that has resulted in a lot, a lot of civilian deaths.
我应该提到，其中只有三人涉及枪手，其余全部是武装直升机和战机的炸弹。所以这并不是个别士兵做了坏事，事实上，在其中两起士兵开枪射杀平民的案例中，他们甚至去了死者家中向家属道歉。所以这里没有士兵胡作非为的证据，但有证据表明，作战风格在很大程度上依赖空权，导致了大量、大量的平民死亡。
I was at a presentation last November, and a pentagon spokesperson said that they've dropped about 50,000 bombs in Iraq. 50,000 bombs. Very, very small fraction of them would need to miss their target or be based on bad information to explain 100,000 civilian deaths.
去年11月我在一场演示中，五角大楼发言人说他们在伊拉克投下了约5万枚炸弹。5万枚炸弹。只要其中非常、非常小的一部分错过了目标或基于错误的情报，就足以解释10万平民的死亡。
At the end of three weeks, there was only one more cluster to survey. The team had saved it for the end, because it was the most dangerous one, Fallujah. Remember, this is September 2004. Insurgents control the city. And it's basically under siege from the Coalition. They're shelling it regularly.
三周结束时，只剩下一个聚类需要调查。团队把它留到了最后，因为它是最危险的一个：费卢杰。记住，这是2004年9月，叛乱分子控制着该市，且该市基本上处于联军的围困下，他们正定期炮击它。
It just seems crazy to go there. And I said to Riyadh, "Riyadh, we have been to 32 of our 33 picked neighborhoods. We actually only thought in the end we would get to 30. We'd aim for 30 and pick 33, with the thought that 10% of places would be too unstable for us to get to.
去那里看起来太疯狂了。我对利雅得说：“利雅得，我们已经走访了33个街区中的32个。其实我们最终只预计能走访30个，我们以30为目标选了33个，认为其中10%的地方可能太不稳定以至于无法到达。”
So we've done better than we expected. We have a terrible story to tell. The mortality is way up. Whatever you find in Fallujah is not going to change the story. Think of what we're going to gain. We're going to gain nothing. And he said, "God picked those random locations. God wants me to do this work. I must do this." And we went back and forth and back and forth and back and forth. And I was brought up Catholic and I had never really thought about it or understood it until that moment in time.
所以我们做得比预期好。我们已经掌握了一个可怕的故事，死亡率大幅上升。无论你在费卢杰发现什么，都不会改变这个结论。想想我们要得到什么，我们一无所获。但他回答：“上帝选了这些随机地点。上帝要我做这项工作。我必须去做。”我们反复辩论。我是信天主教长大的，在那一刻之前我从未真正思考或理解它。
But in my head, I actually sort of build up a weight. What's the likelihood of something bad going to happen to these guys, and how bad is that? What's the likelihood of something good coming from what they do, and how good is that? And I sort of put a weight on each of them.
但在我脑海里，我实际上在权衡：这些人发生不幸的可能性有多大，后果会有多严重？他们所做之事产生积极成果的可能性有多大，成果会有多好？我给每一项都设定了权重。
And I spoke with Riyadh. He actually did not have the capacity to do that, because for him, doing God's will and this work were inseparable. He couldn't separate out risk, because that was separating out sort of faith. The more we spoke, the more I understood that on some very, very fundamental level that we couldn't communicate with each other about our motives here. And in the end he went.
我和利雅得谈了。他实际上没有权衡的能力，因为对他来说，践行上帝的意志和这份工作是不可分割的。他无法剥离风险，因为那意味着剥离信仰。我们聊得越多，我就越明白，在某种非常、非常基础的层面上，我们无法就动机进行沟通。最终，他还是去了。
Only one other interviewer agreed to go to Fallujah with Riyadh. A doctor who had relatives there he wanted to check up on. Their car was stopped three times on the way into the city. Heading to the random spot, they saw devastation everywhere. Houses were bombed. Rubble lay in the streets. The block they stopped on was no different.
只有另一位访谈员同意和利雅得一起去费卢杰。一位在当地有亲戚想去探视的医生。他们的车在进入城市途中被拦下了三次。前往随机点时，他们看到到处是毁灭：房屋被炸毁，瓦砾堆满街道。他们停下的街区也一样。
They had to visit 52 households to get the requisite number of interviews. 23 homes were either temporarily or permanently abandoned. Neighbors said that in the abandoned houses most people had died, but this data couldn't be substantiated. So it wasn't even included in the survey results. In the 30 households they did survey, there were 53 deaths. 52 of these were violent deaths. All but one caused by Coalition weapons. 24 of the people killed by Coalition bombs and bullets (SUBJECT were children under 12 years old. And with that the survey was over.
他们必须走访52户人家才能完成规定数量的访谈。23个家庭要么暂时或永久废弃。邻居说废弃房屋里的人大多数已经死了，但这一数据无法证实，所以甚至没被列入调查结果。在他们走访的30户人家中，有53人死亡，其中52人死于暴力。除一人外，全部死于联军武器。24名死于联军炸弹和子弹的人是12岁以下的儿童。至此，调查结束。
Five days and counting. Tonight, the newest polls, the latest trends, and breaking developments from the campaign trail. On America's News live.
离选举还有五天。今晚，竞选活动中的最新民调、最新趋势和突发动态，尽在《美国新闻直播》。
This is Fox Evening News, October 28th, 2004, on the day of the results of Les's survey, that just shy of 100,000 Iraqis had died as a result of the war, were released. Les had not even considered the Fallujah data in coming up with this number. Fallujah had so many deaths, it was too much of a statistical outlier to even include. Fox never mentioned the study. Neither did ABC or CBS. The only national network that carried the story was NBC for 21 seconds.
这是2004年10月28日的《福克斯晚间新闻》，莱斯的研究结果发布当天——即近10万伊拉克人因战争死亡的结果。莱斯在得出这个数字时甚至没考虑费卢杰的数据。费卢杰死亡人数太多，属于统计异常值，甚至无法包含在内。福克斯从未提及这项研究。美国广播公司（ABC）或哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）也没有。唯一报道此事的全国电视网是全国广播公司（NBC），时长21秒。
Tom, thanks. And we begin here with Iraq watch tonight, and one measure of the high cost of war. A new study from Johns Hopkins University estimates that 100,000 Iraqi civilians have died since the start of the war. The majority as a result of US air strikes. This is a much larger figure than some previous estimates. The Pentagon had no comment on the number, but said it had taken great care to prevent civilian deaths. And there is--
“汤姆，谢谢。我们从今晚的伊拉克观察开始，这是衡量战争高昂代价的一种方式。约翰霍普金斯大学的一项新研究估计，自战争开始以来，已有10万名伊拉克平民死亡，其中大多数是美军空袭的结果。这比之前的一些估计数字大得多。五角大楼对此数字未予置评，但表示在防止平民死亡方面非常小心。目前——”
Morning Edition and All Things Considered on NPR devoted 45 seconds to the story. It didn't make the front page of the New York Times, the Washington Post or any national newspaper.
国家公共广播电台（NPR）的《早间新闻》和《万事皆备》节目用了45秒报道这个新闻。它没有登上《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》或任何全国性报纸的头版。
The Iraq study had provided information about the war that up until that point no one had been able to provide. The number it gave was much higher than anyone would have expected. It was just as accurate as Les's previous studies in Africa that he had done using the exact same methods. And which were widely reported in the press and quoted by lawmakers. His Congo study was page one in the New York Times. The only differences with this study where that he'd risked his life to do it and it was about Iraq, which, if anything, should have made it more interesting to the media.
这项伊拉克研究提供了战争信息，直到那时没人能提供这些信息。它给出的数字比任何人预期的都要高得多。它和莱斯之前在非洲使用完全相同方法进行的调查一样准确，而那些调查被媒体广泛报道，并被立法者引用。他的刚果研究曾是《纽约时报》头版新闻。这项研究唯一的不同点在于，他冒着生命危险完成它，而且它是关于伊拉克的——这本来应该让媒体更感兴趣。
So why didn't it get any press? Partly, it was the timing. The study came out five days before the US election, and so the media was pretty preoccupied. Plus, there was a suspicion that the team had timed the release of the survey specifically to influence the election. A suspicion that Les didn't really help dispel.
那么为什么它没得到媒体关注呢？部分原因是时机。研究在美军选举前五天发布，所以媒体非常忙碌。此外，有一种怀疑是该团队专门选择这个时间发布调查是为了影响选举。莱斯并没有真正澄清这种怀疑。
He said to an AP reporter about the study, quote, "I emailed it on September 30th, under the condition that it come out before the election. My motive in doing that was not to skew the election. My motive was that if this came out during the campaign, both candidates would be forced to pledge to protect civilian lives in Iraq. I was opposed to the war, and I still think the war was a bad idea. But I think that our science has transcended our perspectives. As an American, I'm really, really sorry to be reporting this."
他曾对美联社记者谈及这项研究时说：“我在9月30日通过电子邮件发送了它，条件是它必须在选举前发布。我这么做的动机不是为了歪曲选举。我的动机是，如果这在竞选期间发布，两位候选人都将被迫承诺保护伊拉克平民的生命。我反对这场战争，现在依然认为战争是个坏主意。但我认为我们的科学已经超越了我们的视角。作为一名美国人，我真的、真的很遗憾要报告这些。”
One desk editor at a national news organization told me that when the study came out, he sent an email to one of his colleagues saying, The Lancet had, in the past, published some studies with a political slant. But that this study seemed sound, and maybe they should report on it. Then he saw Les's comments, and he didn't follow up. This is exactly the type of story that those who believe the media has a liberal bias love to pounce on. And so in essence, if the research turns out to be flawed, this desk editor's organization gets the heat for it.
一家全国性新闻机构的一位编辑告诉我，研究发布时，他给同事发了封邮件，说《柳叶刀》过去发表过一些有政治倾向的研究。但这项研究看起来很扎实，也许他们应该报道。然后他看到了莱斯的评论，他没再跟进。这正是那些认为媒体有自由派偏见的人喜欢抓住的那种故事。所以本质上，如果研究结果被证明有缺陷，这位编辑的机构就会受到指责。
He had a very small window of time during a very busy news cycle, to decide whether the study was legit or just an angry and easily debunked researcher pushing an agenda. And Les's comments seemed to be all the evidence he needed.
他在繁忙的新闻周期中只有一个非常小的时间窗口，来决定这项研究是合法的，还是一个愤怒且容易被揭穿的研究人员在推动某种议程。而莱斯的评论似乎是他所需要的全部证据。
And there was one other thing that made it easy for the media to dismiss the report. A researcher at Human Rights Watch, who himself had done studies of civilian casualties during wartime, said he didn't believe the study. The researcher's name was Marc Garlasco, and he told a reporter for The Washington Post, quote, "The number seems high to me." And quote, "It seems like a stretch."
还有一件事让媒体很容易驳回这份报告。人权观察组织的一名研究人员，他自己也做过战时平民伤亡研究，说他不相信这项研究。这位研究人员叫马克·加拉斯科，他告诉《华盛顿邮报》记者：“这个数字对我来说太高了，感觉有点夸大。”
I was actually on the Long Island railroad when he called me. It was some time in the evening, and I had yet to read Les's report.
他打电话给我时，我其实正在长岛铁路的火车上。那是傍晚，我还没读过莱斯的报告。
This is Marc Garlasco. He said he told the reporter from The Post that he hadn't read the study. But the reporter said he really needed a quote, and could he just respond to the number. Garlasco's quote was cited elsewhere and he appeared on CNN, although none of the study's authors were interviewed on CNN or any of the major networks. Here's what Marc Garlasco says now.
这就是马克·加拉斯科。他说他告诉《华盛顿邮报》记者他没读过这项研究，但记者说他真的需要一个评论，能不能就这个数字发表一下看法。加拉斯科的评论被其他媒体引用，他还在CNN露面，尽管该研究的任何作者都没有在CNN或任何主流电视网接受过采访。马克·加拉斯科现在这么说：
First of all, I'm not a statistician. I know absolutely nothing about it. And when I then went and spoke to statisticians they said, well, you know the method that he's using is a really accurate one. This is something that we use in studies all throughout the world, and it's a generally accepted model. And that kind of made me think about it. Think about my prejudices going into reading his report. Because I had been on the ground, in Iraq, immediately after the war. But I also had taken part in the targeting for the war.
“首先，我不是统计学家，对此一窍不通。当我后来去请教统计学家时，他们说，他用的方法真的很准确。这是我们在全世界的研究中都在使用的方法，是一个被普遍接受的模型。这让我反思，反思我在阅读他报告时的偏见。因为我曾在战后立即在伊拉克实地工作过。但我同时也参与了这场战争的打击目标规划。”
OK, let's just stop here for one minute. You heard what he said. He'd taken part in the targeting for the war. Get ready, because this story's about to take a turn. Marc Garlasco isn't your typical human rights advocate.
好的，让我们在这里停一分钟。你听到了他说的，他参与了这场战争的打击目标规划。做好心理准备，因为这个故事要发生转变了。马克·加拉斯科不是你典型的“人权倡导者”。
Well, I worked in the Pentagon almost seven years. And my last job there was chief of high-value targeting on the joint staff. And basically that means that I was one of many people that was involved in the tracking and attempted killing of Saddam Hussein and all those people in the deck of cards. And I would sit there with my compatriots, and we would put x's on buildings one day, and the next day those buildings are gone.
“我在五角大楼工作了近七年，最后一份工作是联合参谋部的高价值目标首席规划员。基本上意味着我是众多参与追踪并试图杀死萨达姆·侯赛因以及扑克牌名单上那些人的人之一。我会和同事们坐在一起，今天在建筑上画叉，第二天那些建筑就消失了。”
So you were literally in this last invasion?
所以你真的参与了这次入侵？
Absolutely. I was involved in the war planning. In January of '03, I was involved in the final targeting of Iraq. When we put the final target list together, and of course those got brushed up as we got closer to the war.
“当然。我参与了战争规划。03年1月，我参与了伊拉克的最终打击目标规划。当我们整理最终目标名单时，当然，随着战争临近，这些名单又进行了修改。”
During the war, I was working 18 hours a day, at least, in the Pentagon. Putting in hours, trying to get and kill Saddam Hussein and others. And after Baghdad fell and then on April 11, I walked out of the Pentagon. And it was a Friday. And then on Monday morning I walked into Human Rights Watch, and suddenly I'm now a human rights advocate. And got on a plane and flew to Iraq to see my handiwork.
“战争期间，我在五角大楼每天至少工作18个小时。为了找到并杀死萨达姆·侯赛因和其他人。巴格达陷落后，4月11日，我走出了五角大楼。那是周五，周一早上我走进人权观察组织，突然我现在成了人权倡导者，买了张机票飞往伊拉克去看我的‘作品’。”
That literally, how soon after?
这真的，是多久之后？
Literally, it was just the next week. Got onto a plane and went to Iraq. And I was standing there in craters that I had helped cause.
“就在下周。坐飞机去了伊拉克。我站在我参与造成的弹坑里。”
Marc doesn't see moving from the Pentagon to a human rights nonprofit as the 180 degree flip most people might. He says all he's ever wanted to do is fight bad guys and both organizations do that, just in different ways. He'd been thinking about leaving the military before the war began, and he hadn't supported the war himself. But he stayed through the fall of Baghdad, because he knew the target set better than anyone else. And he figured if there was going to be a war anyway, it might as well be him targeting the bombs rather than someone else who might not know or care as much as he did.
马克并不认为从五角大楼转到人权非营利组织是一个大多数人认为的180度大转弯。他说他一直想做的就是打击坏人，而这两个组织都做到了，只是方式不同。他在战争开始前就考虑离开军队，他自己并不支持这场战争。但他坚持留到巴格达陷落，因为他比任何人都更了解打击目标设定。他觉得如果无论如何都要打仗，那么由他来规划炸弹目标，总比那些可能不了解情况或不像他那样在乎的人要好。
The thing that finally prompted him to leave, he says, didn't have anything to do with the war. His wife got a great job offer at the Bronx zoo, and they'd always wanted to move back to New York. When Marc went with Human Rights Watch to Iraq, it wasn't to get a comprehensive count of civilian casualties. His mission was to look at specific attacks and see which kinds of attacks caused high civilian death tolls. Because Marc had planned many of the strikes he was now going to investigate, it was a little complicated.
他说他最终离开的原因与战争无关。他妻子在布朗克斯动物园得到了一份很棒的工作机会，他们一直想搬回纽约。马克随人权观察组织去伊拉克时，并不是为了获得平民伤亡的综合统计。他的任务是观察特定攻击，看看哪些类型的攻击导致了平民死亡。由于马克计划了许多他现在要去调查的攻击，情况变得有点复杂。
There was the attack on Chemical Ali in Basra. And I'll never forget sitting in this tiny cubicle, in the bowels of the Pentagon, watching it on the television as we had the predator overhead. And you're watching this black and white screen, because it's a night shot. And anything that's white is hot and black is cold.
“那次在巴士拉针对‘化学阿里’的攻击。我永远不会忘记坐在五角大楼深处那个小隔间里，在电视上看它，当时我们有掠食者无人机在头上。你看着这个黑白屏幕，因为是夜拍，白色的是热的，黑色的是冷的。”
And we're watching people walking in front of it. And all of a sudden, this building just erupts and was gone. And we watched as bodies flew out of it. And you could see the legs kicking in the air like rag dolls. And we just erupted in cheers. And we were ecstatic.
“我们在看屏幕上的人走过，突然间，这栋建筑就爆发了，消失了。我们看着尸体从里面飞出来。你可以看到腿像破布娃娃一样在空中踢蹬。我们当时欢呼雀跃，兴奋不已。”
Here we are. We killed Chemical Ali. This is great. And what is it, three weeks later I'm standing in the crater with this 70-year-old man who's got tears in his eyes. And he's telling me how 17 members of his family, including his grandchildren, were killed. and I still feel very mixed emotions about the whole situation, the whole experience.
“就在这里，我们杀了‘化学阿里’。这太棒了。结果三周后，我站在弹坑里，看着这个眼中含泪的70岁老头。他告诉我他家里17口人，包括孙辈，是如何被杀的。至今我对整件事、整个经历仍怀着非常复杂的情感。”
What are those mixed emotions on the one side and on the other?
那是一方面和另一方面复杂情感分别是什么？
Well, on the one side, I feel like I took part in this wholesale slaughter of this guy's family, which is very difficult to swallow. But on the other side, I know that we truly, truly did what we could. We were going after some very bad people-- war criminals. Chemical Ali had gassed the Kurds. He was singularly responsible for thousands of deaths. And so, he was certainly a legitimate military target.
“一方面，我觉得我参与了这家人被大规模屠杀的事件，这很难接受。但另一方面，我知道我们确实竭尽所能了。我们在对付一些非常坏的家伙——战争罪犯。‘化学阿里’曾向库尔德人投毒气。他应对数千人的死亡负有单一人责任。所以，他当然是一个合法的军事打击目标。”
But I think this just goes to show how difficult the job really is. This is one of those strikes where we did everything right. Where we thought we had the bad guy. Where it was weaponeered correctly. And yet, it just was the wrong place to hit at that time and people died for it.
“但我认为这正好说明了这项工作有多么困难。这是我们‘做对了一切’的打击之一，我们以为抓到了坏人，目标规划是正确的，然而那只是当时不该轰炸的地方，人们因此而死。”
The attack had hit the intended buildings, but it also destroyed the two neighboring buildings. That's where the man's family had died. Also, Chemical Ali hadn't been in the targeted building anyway. It's unclear who died there.
那次攻击击中了预定建筑，但也摧毁了相邻的两栋。那男人的家人就是死在那里。而且，‘化学阿里’当时根本不在目标建筑里。不清楚谁死在那里。
Marc went to lots of places in Iraq he'd studied on maps and aerial photographs and heard about from defectors. And there's no way around this. After all those years of imagining these places, what they must be like, it was exciting to actually be there.
马克去了伊拉克许多他在地图和航空照片上研究过、从叛逃者口中听说过的地方。这一点无可避讳，经过多年的想象，亲自去过之后，还是感到非常兴奋。
I was walking through bunkers that I knew about. I went to Saddam Hussein's bunker. I went to his family's bunkers. One of my favorite moments was when I actually met one of the bunker builders and hired him as a translator. And he took us into Sajida's palace. Sajida was Saddam's wife. And we knew that there was a bunker under the building, and we had targeted it and dropped a weapon into it.
“我走过我熟知的掩体。我去了萨达姆·侯赛因的掩体，去了他家人的掩体。我最喜欢的时刻之一是我遇到了其中一个掩体建造者，并聘请他做翻译。他带我们进了萨吉达的宫殿。萨吉达是萨达姆的妻子。我们知道建筑下有个掩体，并已将其锁定并投下一枚武器。”
And he took me in. And we go into the building. And I'm seeing the inside for the first time, which had before only been described to me by defectors. And here it is and it's this picture that had been painted in my mind. And we get there and the guy says, now I will walk you down to the bunker. And we walk down to it, and we get to the bunker.
“他带我进去。我们进入建筑。我第一次亲眼看到内部，之前只有叛逃者描述过。它就是我想象中被描绘的那样。我们到了那儿，那家伙说，现在我带你去掩体。我们走下去，到了掩体。”
And when we look down on it from the top, there's a whole as the Penetrator went in through the four floors, straight down into the bunker. And he looks at me and he says, whoever did this was a very smart man. And I lost it. I just completely lost it.
“从上面俯瞰时，有一个洞，因为穿甲弹穿过了四层楼，径直打进掩体里。他看着我说，干这件事的人肯定是个非常聪明的人。我失控了，我彻底失控了。”
Because you're like, I did that.
因为你感觉就像，我干的。
I was like, hey thanks. I appreciate it.
我当时说，嘿，谢谢。我很感激。
The military denied my request to talk on the record about civilian casualties. But Marc Garlasco says that civilian casualties are one of the primary factors he and his colleagues considered when planning the war. Say he had a target he wanted to take out. The headquarters of the Iraqi Secret Service maybe or one of Saddam's palaces. He'd work with the weaponeering guys to figure out how many and which bombs to use, and then--
军方拒绝了我采访平民伤亡记录的请求。但马克·加拉斯科说，平民伤亡是他在规划战争时与同事考虑的首要因素之一。假设他有个想要干掉的目标，可能是伊拉克特勤局总部或者萨达姆的宫殿之一，他会与武器规划人员合作计算使用多少枚炸弹，然后——
Once that's established, they'll work up these collateral damage estimates and tell you, OK, in this strike 10 people are anticipated to be killed. Civilians or 20 civilians or whatever. And in this war in Iraq there was a magic number. And the magic number was 30. And for any target where it was anticipated that 30 civilians or more would be killed, it required the signature of either the President or the Secretary of Defense for that strike to actually occur.
“一旦确定，他们就会制定这些附带损害评估并告诉你，好的，这次打击预计会有10人死亡，平民或20名平民等。在伊拉克这场战争中有一个神奇的数字，就是30。对于预计会导致30名或以上平民死亡的任何打击，都需要总统或国防部长的亲笔签名，该打击才能发生。”
How was that magic number arrived at? Do you know?
这个神奇数字是怎么得来的？你知道吗？
I have absolutely no idea how the magic number came to be 30.
我完全不知道这个数字30是怎么来的。
A lot of times, when the collateral damage assessment came back too high, they'd try to get it lowered. For example, a strike Marc planned early on in the invasion. An Iraqi division was holed up in a big multi-building convention center in Baghdad, which unfortunately was right across the street from a hospital.
很多时候，当附带损害评估结果太高时，他们会试图降低它。例如，马克在入侵初期计划的一次打击。一个伊拉克师盘踞在巴格达一个大型多建筑会议中心里，不幸的是，它就在医院对面。
Now because of the amount of guys there and the construction of the buildings, we knew that they needed to use 2,000 pound bombs. The problem with this is a 2,000 pound bomb has a very large, destructive radius. And it certainly would have enveloped the hospital. But there are things that you can do, even when you're dropping large munitions, to reduce civilian casualties. One of those is to change the angle of attack.
“因为那里的人数和建筑结构，我们知道需要使用2000磅炸弹。问题是2000磅炸弹有很大的破坏半径，肯定会吞没医院。但即使投掷大威力弹药，你也可以采取措施减少平民伤亡。其中之一就是改变攻击角度。”
And so imagine if you will, a plane is coming in and drops bombs at such an angle that they actually push the debris away from the direction of the hospital. Additionally, you put a time delayed fuse on it. And, in this case, I think it was maybe five nanoseconds. Which is an incredibly short period of time, but it's enough that it allows the bomb to bury itself in the ground. And what this does is it basically lets the building implode. And it falls in upon itself and contains a lot of that blast and fragmentation damage that would come out and injure civilians or destroy some of the hospital.
“想象一下，如果一架飞机进场并在这样一个角度投弹，碎片会被推离医院方向。此外，你装上延时引信。在这个案例中，我想可能是5纳秒。虽然时间极短，但足以让炸弹钻入地下。这本质上会让建筑内爆，它会向内坍塌，包含住了原本会喷射出来并伤害平民或摧毁医院的大部分冲击波和碎片破坏力。”
And then additionally you're using a penetrating warhead, so it's burying into the ground. So you're not just willy-nilly dropping bombs like in the Second World War.
“而且你使用的是穿甲弹头，所以它钻进地里了。所以你不是像二战那样漫无目的地乱投炸弹。”
When I got there, I went into the hospital and spoke to the director and all the people in there. And nothing worse than a few broken windows. And I was like, wow, this is great. We did a really good job on this one.
“我到那里后，走进医院和院长及所有人谈过，结果没有什么比几扇破碎的窗户更严重的了。我想，哇，这太棒了，我们这次干得真漂亮。”
What got Marc thinking about civilian casualties in the first place, was a battle damage assessment he did after the war in Kosovo. He targeted the bombs for that war. And then afterwards, the military sent him over to see how well he'd done. He measured how often the bombs hit their targets. Whether they destroyed what they were supposed to destroy. Pretty much the only thing he didn't check the accuracy of were the collateral damage assessments.
让马克最初开始思考平民伤亡的，是科索沃战争后他做的战损评估。他曾为那场战争规划炸弹目标，事后，军方派他去看看自己干得如何。他测量了炸弹命中目标的频率，是否摧毁了原本要摧毁的东西。几乎他没检查准确性的唯一一件事，就是附带损害评估。
That's what got me. That's what really surprised me. At no point in time did we ever have to report back on civilian casualties. And so my question has always been, if the weapons worked correctly, if the targets were correct, shouldn't you also be asking were your civilian casualty estimates correct? Shouldn't that be factored into it, to make sure that your models are accurate? Because if your models are not accurate, what are they worth? Why do you even bother doing it? it's just throwing darts at a board at that point.
“就是这一点困扰着我。这是真正让我惊讶的地方。我们从来不需要报告平民伤亡。所以我的问题一直是，如果武器运行正确，如果目标正确，难道你不应该同时问：你们的平民伤亡估计准确吗？难道不应该把它作为因素考虑进去，以确保你们的模型是准确的吗？因为如果你们的模型不准确，那它们还有什么价值？为什么要费那个劲去做呢？那只不过是在盲目投掷而已。”
Wow. Did you ever find out an answer to that question?
哇。你找到那个问题的答案了吗？
No, but it's something that I keep asking the military now that I'm in Human Rights Watch. When I was there I was wondering why isn't it done. And now I asked them why isn't it done, and why don't you do it. And I guess the answer that I get back just hasn't satisfied me. It's look, we're still fighting a war in Iraq. It's really hard to do. Or it's very difficult to account for civilian casualties, for a variety of reasons.
没有，但这是我加入人权观察组织后一直在问军方的问题。我当时在想为什么不这么做。现在我问他们为什么不这么做，你们为什么不这么做。得到的回答没能让我满意。回复是：看，我们还在伊拉克打仗，这真的很难做到；或者因为各种原因，统计平民伤亡非常困难。
And you get the bureaucratic double-talk. And it's just not good enough, because I've been there, and I know that people care and want to do the very best they can. And they don't want to kill civilians. And here's an opportunity to really make a difference, and to show that you're doing your utmost best to make sure that you're upholding the Geneva Convention and not killing people unnecessarily.
你只会得到官僚主义的套话。这根本不够，因为我亲历过，我知道人们很关心，想要竭尽全力。他们不想杀平民。这是一个真正做出改变、展示你们在竭尽全力确保遵守《日内瓦公约》且不无谓杀人的机会。
In talking to people in the military, off the record, I heard a couple of arguments against counting civilian deaths. First they say, it's not the military's job. What you're trying to do is win a battle. It could be a dangerous, and in the long run, counterproductive distraction to worry about counting all the civilians you accidentally kill along the way. Second, and perhaps more persuasively, they say no one would believe them anyway.
在与军方人士私下交谈时，我听到了几个反对统计平民死亡的论点。首先，他们说这不是军队的工作。你的目标是打赢战斗。担心统计你沿途意外杀害的所有平民可能会成为危险的，长远来看适得其反的分心之举。第二点，或许更有说服力，他们说反正也没人会相信。
Just ask Les Roberts. Even though Les's study didn't get much mainstream attention, it did provoke, like so many things these days, a bitter debate on the internet. The attacks came mainly, though not exclusively, from right-wing blogs. Several charges leveled at the study were simply untrue, and seemed designed to willfully muddy the waters.
问问莱斯·罗伯茨就知道了。虽然莱斯的研究没有获得太多主流媒体关注，但它确实像如今的许多事情一样，在互联网上引发了激烈的争论。攻击主要（并非全部）来自右翼博客。对该研究提出的几项指控纯属不实，似乎是有意搅浑水。
For example, there was a claim repeatedly made, both in the press and online, that the data weren't random because the researchers had been blocked from going certain places. Or had decided against certain places because it was too dangerous. This is simply false. A couple of people suggested that the researchers had gone to Fallujah, on purpose, to boost their numbers, even though exactly the opposite was true. Les had wanted to skip Fallujah altogether, and they hadn't even included the data in their final casualty estimate.
例如，媒体和网络上反复声称，数据不随机是因为研究人员被禁止前往某些地方，或者因为太危险而决定不去某些地方。这纯属谎言。还有几个人暗示研究人员特意去了费卢杰以抬高数字，尽管事实恰恰相反。莱斯根本想跳过费卢杰，而且他们甚至没把该数据包含在最终的伤亡估计中。
Several objections had merit though. First of all, the study makes no distinction between combatants and civilians. Les actually acknowledged this in the study itself, and went to great lengths not to claim, as others did on his behalf, that the study was a measure of civilian mortality. Certainly some of the people the Coalition killed, they intended to kill. But half of all the casualties were women and children, so even in the unlikely event that 50% of the men who died were actually fighting us, it's still a large number of innocents.
但有几个反对意见是有道理的。首先，该研究没有区分战斗人员和平民。莱斯在研究中实际上承认了这一点，并尽力不去宣称——正如其他人代他宣称的那样——这项研究是衡量平民死亡率的标准。联军杀害的人中确实有一些是他们意图杀害的，但伤亡者中有一半是妇女和儿童，所以即使按不太可能的概率，50%死亡的男性实际上是在与我们交战，那依然有大量无辜者。
The critique that got most traction on the internet though has to do with something called the confidence interval. Let's take an election poll as an example. Candidate X is projected to receive 55% of the vote. What that really means is that he's projected to receive some percentage within two numbers, let's say 52% and 58%. That range is called the confidence interval.
在互联网上获得最多关注的批判是关于所谓的“置信区间”。让我们以选举民调为例，候选人X预计获得55%的选票。这实际上意味着他预计获得两个数字之间的某个百分比，假设是52%到58%。这个范围被称为“置信区间”。
The confidence interval in Les's survey was very wide, between 8,000 and 194,000. It was this wide for a lot of reasons, but mainly because the sample is relatively small relative to the population. And because violent death, unlike death due to malaria or diarrhea, isn't very uniformly distributed.
莱斯调查的置信区间非常大，在8000到194000之间。这有许多原因，但主要是因为相对于总体人口样本较小，且因为暴力死亡与死于疟疾或腹泻不同，分布并不均匀。
So you have Kurdish areas where mortality actually went down during the war, versus Fallujah, which averaged almost two violent deaths per household. Such a wide confidence interval means that, statistically speaking, Les's estimate of 100,000 dead isn't very precise. The number could be thousands or tens of thousands smaller or equally likely, bigger.
所以你有库尔德地区，那里的战争期间死亡率实际上下降了，而费卢杰平均每个家庭有近两次暴力死亡。如此宽阔的置信区间意味着，从统计学上讲，莱斯10万死亡的估计不是很精确。数字可能会少几千甚至几万，或者同样可能，会更多。
But a lot of people made wrong conclusions from the wide confidence interval. They interpreted it to mean it was just as likely that 8,000 people had died as it was that 100,000 had. The online magazine Slate wrote, This isn't an estimate. It's a dart board. In fact, the likelihood follows a bell curve, with 98,000 being at the top of the bell, the most likely number. So actually, there's only a 2.5% chance that the number is 8,000 or below. But a 90% chance that it's 44,000 or above. Here's Les.
但许多人从宽阔的置信区间中得出了错误的结论。他们将其解释为：死8000人和死10万人可能性一样大。在线杂志《Slate》写道：“这根本不是估计，这是飞镖盘。”事实上，概率遵循钟形曲线，98000处在钟形顶端，是最可能的数字。所以实际上，数字在8000或以下的概率只有2.5%，而数字在44000或以上的概率有90%。听听莱斯的看法。
A couple of people told me that that Sunday before the election their minister from the pulpit had said, this study in The Lancet was flawed and wrong. And my next door neighbor, who was listening to talk radio, spoke to me the day of the election. And she said, well I just heard on talk radio today that The Lancet study finding 8,000 Iraqi deaths was flawed and wrong. And so it was discussed, but I don't think it was discussed in a very sort of scientifically rigorous process.
“有几个人告诉我，在选举前那个星期天，他们的牧师在讲坛上说，《柳叶刀》的这项研究有缺陷且是错误的。我邻居在听谈话广播，选举那天跟我说，今天在广播里听说《柳叶刀》研究发现的8000人伊拉克死亡数字有缺陷且是错误的。所以，人们确实讨论了它，但我不认为讨论过程很科学严谨。”
Clearly, the people on talk radio weren't attacking the study out of a commitment to experimental rigor. They were attacking it for the same reason that the news media was hesitant to report it. Because the very act of counting civilian casualties is political.
显然，谈话广播节目的人并不是出于对实验严谨性的执着而攻击这项研究。他们攻击它是为了和新闻媒体犹豫报道它一样的原因：因为统计平民伤亡本身就是政治性的。
The moral logic of war is this. We're willing to undergo x number of costs in lives, money, resources to accomplish some goal. The goal, we hope, will be worth it in the end. So assuming the goal in Iraq is good, is it wrong to kill 100,000 civilians? Saddam himself probably killed 230,000 of his own people. A number, by the way, no one seems to go out of their way to dispute. If you add the million or so lives he lost in the futile war he launched against Iran, 100,000 seems like a bargain in comparison.
战争的道德逻辑是这样的：我们愿意付出一定数量的生命、金钱、资源成本来完成某个目标。我们希望这个目标最终是值得的。所以，假设在伊拉克的目标是好的，杀死10万平民是错误的吗？萨达姆本人可能杀了23万他自己的人民——顺便说一句，这个数字似乎没人会去争论。如果你加上他在对伊朗发动的徒劳战争中损失的约100万生命，相比之下，10万似乎是“划算”的。
Maybe he would have gone on another killing spree, and this 100,000 is insurance against the later, far worse death toll. Or maybe 100,000 lives is worth it, if in the end democracy does blossom through the Middle East. After all, we killed far more Japanese with just two atomic bombs than, according to Les, we did in a year and a half in Iraq.
也许他会继续进行另一场杀戮狂潮，而这10万是防止后来更惨重死亡人数的保险。又或者，如果最终民主能在中东开花结果，10万生命就是值得的。毕竟，根据莱斯的统计，我们在伊拉克一年半造成的死亡，远少于我们仅用两枚原子弹在日本人身上造成的死亡。
If we don't count civilian casualties, we don't have to get into this kind of horrible math. And most of us don't want to. So instead, we leave it to the professionals. The military are the only ones who even try to come up with a formula, the collateral damage assessment. 30 dead civilians for one bad guy. For Les, he doesn't really care who counts, just so long as someone does.
如果我们不统计平民伤亡，我们就不必陷入这种可怕的数学。大多数人也不想。所以，我们把它留给专业人士。军方是唯一试图提出公式——附带损害评估——的人。每个坏人换30个死亡平民。对于莱斯来说，他并不真正在意是谁在统计，只要有人做就行。
Under the Geneva Conventions, an occupying army's relationship to the occupied is roughly the same as a police department's relationship to its population. And in my hometown, if a policeman pulls out his gun and shoots six shots at someone, another policeman will come and try to find where each of those six bullets landed and decide, was this excessive use of force.
“根据《日内瓦公约》，占领军与被占领者的关系，大体上与警察部门与民众的关系相同。在我的家乡，如果有警察拔枪向某人开了六枪，另一名警察会赶来试图找出那六颗子弹每一颗都落在了哪里，并决定，这是否属于过度武力。”
And well, how can we say that we are really looking after the well being of the Iraqi folks, people, if we don't sort of go through some sort of minimal effort to decide what are we doing to them, and what can we do to limit the adverse consequences.
“那么，如果我们不做任何最基本的努力来确定我们对他们做了什么，以及我们可以做些什么来限制不良后果，我们怎么能说我们真的在照顾伊拉克人民的福祉呢？”
One of the most surprising things Les discovered in Iraq is that, despite what everyone says about the difficulty of counting civilian casualties during wartime, it's actually not that hard. The survey teams got participation rates that most American pollsters would kill for. Only 5 of the 988 households the team surveyed refused to answer the questions. And people were able to provide death certificates over 80% of the time.
莱斯在伊拉克发现的最令人惊讶的事情之一是，尽管每个人都说战时统计平民伤亡很难，但实际上并不难。调查小组获得了大多数美国民调机构梦寐以求的参与率。在团队走访的988户人家中，只有5户拒绝回答问题，且人们在80%以上的情况下都能提供死亡证明。
That confidence interval, Les is sure that based on the results of the first survey and with a little more money-- remember, this whole thing cost only $40,000-- he could design a follow-up survey that would narrow that interval way down. We can count civilian casualties in wartime. We just have to want to.
关于那个置信区间，莱斯确定，基于第一次调查的结果，再多一点资金——记住，这一切总共才花了4万美元——他可以设计一项后续调查，将那个区间缩小很多。我们可以在战时统计平民伤亡，我们只是必须想要这么做。
Alex Blumberg. Coming up, so a military that's trying as hard as it can not to kill civilians makes a mistake. What do they do then. Well, we have a recording of what they do then. Also, we take a look at the new Lancet study. The sequel to the one you just heard about. It just came out two weeks ago. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
亚历克斯·布伦伯格。接下来，那么一支正在尽力避免杀害平民的军队犯了错误，他们该怎么办？嗯，我们有一段他们当时行动的录音。此外，我们将回顾新的《柳叶刀》研究，那项你刚才听到的研究的续篇，它在两周前刚刚发布。稍后马上回来。来自芝加哥公共广播和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
Well it's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, What's in a Number. In Act One of our show, we heard about the number of Iraqi deaths that occurred in the first year and a half after the US invasion. And this is no longer true in Iraq, but at the time, according to this Johns Hopkins Study we were talking about, the majority of deaths were caused by the US-led forces. Despite everything they did to avoid Iraqi deaths.
嗯，这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目是“数字的意义”。在我们的第一幕中，我们听到了美军入侵后前一年半发生的伊拉克死亡人数。而在当时，虽然现在在伊拉克情况已不再如此，但根据我们讨论的那项约翰霍普金斯大学的研究，大多数死亡是由美国领导的联军造成的，尽管他们采取了一切措施来避免伊拉克人死亡。
Well, now we're going to move to Act Two, where we hear US forces trying to cope in the aftermath of some of those deaths.
好的，现在我们要进入第二幕，去听听美军如何试图应对其中一些死亡事件的余波。
This is Act Two, Not Just a Number. The civilian deaths, in this particular story came at a unusually bad time for Captain Ryan Gist. He was the American officer in charge of the US Army presence in a section of the Nineveh and Salahuddin provinces in Iraq, a Sunni area. And this meant that he dealt with everything from seeing that the region had water and fuel to dislodging insurgents and winning over the local population. He faced all sorts of problems.
这是第二幕，“不仅仅是一个数字”。在这个特定故事中，平民死亡事件发生在瑞安·吉斯特上尉异常糟糕的时候。他是负责伊拉克尼尼微省和萨拉赫丁省部分地区（逊尼派地区）美军驻扎的美国指挥官。这意味着他要处理从确保该地区有水和燃料，到清除叛乱分子和赢得当地民众支持的一切事务。他面临着各种各样的问题。
On November 10th, 2004, for example, insurgents blew up most of the police stations in this area. And the next day, Iraqi Army and police simply stopped showing up for their jobs. One town called Atha was especially troublesome. The US had not made many allies there.
例如，2004年11月10日，叛乱分子炸毁了该地区大部分警察局。第二天，伊拉克军队和警察干脆就不来上班了。一个叫阿萨的城镇特别麻烦。美军在那里没交到什么朋友。
And it was turning into probably the greatest threat to stability in our region. So to begin with, we knew we were going into a very hot spot. So we went in. And for weeks we'd go in there and we would try to talk to leaders, try and talk to people, and they were scared. The terrorists literally had a grip on everybody. And that is the challenge in Iraq. And what it takes is just feet on the ground, every day, going to different houses and just talking to people.
“它正在变成我们地区稳定面临的可能是最大的威胁。所以首先，我们知道我们要进入一个非常热点的地方。所以我们进去了。几周来我们一直在那里，试图与领袖交谈，试图与人们交谈，但他们很害怕。恐怖分子简直控制着每一个人。这就是在伊拉克的挑战。而所需要的只是脚踏实地，每天去不同的房子，只是和人们交谈。”
And finally we found someone whose family had been killed-- every one of them had been killed by the terrorists within the last month-- and he wanted revenge. And he wanted to see his town free of this threat.
“最终我们找到了一个人，他的家人——他们所有人——在过去一个月内都被恐怖分子杀害了，他想要复仇。他希望能看到自己的城镇免于这种威胁。”
So the guy gives him names and locations of people that he identifies as insurgents. And the army launches an operation to get those people. And this is where things went wrong. As part of this operation, the US forces were supposed to drop a bomb into a nearby field, just as a show of force.
那个人给了他被确认为叛乱分子的姓名和地点。军队发起了一次行动去抓捕这些人。而问题就出在这。作为行动的一部分，美军本应向附近的田野投下一枚炸弹，只是为了展示武力。
But instead, the bomb was dropped onto the house that the army was just about to raid, killing 12 people inside, including children. And nearly killing the US troops who were about to go in. That's according to an American photojournalist, Sheryl Mendez, who was there. In addition to the human tragedy of these deaths, for Captain Gist this could not have been worse.
但相反，炸弹被投到了军队即将突袭的房子上，导致里面12人死亡，包括儿童。而且差点把即将进入的美军部队炸死。这是根据当时在场的美国摄影记者谢丽尔·门德斯的说法。除了这些死亡事件的人道悲剧外，对吉斯特上尉来说，情况再糟不过了。
It was the hardest time of my life. And the most difficult part for us was in the weeks afterwards. We have to show that it was an accident. And that we are someone who can be trusted, and we are here to help them.
“那是我一生中最艰难的时刻。对我们来说最困难的部分是随后的几周。我们必须证明那是一次意外。我们必须证明我们是值得信任的人，我们来这里是为了帮助他们。”
The photographer, Sheryl Mendez, tape-recorded him as he went to the sheiks, who were the local leaders and to the police, as he went around trying to make things right. Here's one of those recordings. He's in a police station.
摄影师谢丽尔·门德斯录下了他去见作为当地领袖的谢赫（酋长）和警察，四处试图修复关系时的录音。这是其中一段录音。他当时在警察局里。
I'm here for a couple reasons today. The first reason is to express my regrets to you.
“今天我来这里有两个原因。第一个原因是向你们表示我的遗憾。”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
I feel much pain in my heart for what happened.
“对于发生的事情，我心中深感痛苦。”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
We did not intend to hurt any innocent people here.
“我们在这里无意伤害任何无辜的人。”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
We did not mean for any women and children to die.
“我们从未打算让任何妇女和儿童死亡。”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
I had men hurt in the explosion as well.
“我也在爆炸中受了伤。”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
You're sitting there in a room with five, six, seven people that are definitely angry at you. They believe you did it intentionally. That hate you for being in the town in the first place.
“你坐在一个房间里，有五、六、七个人肯定在生你的气。他们认为你是故意这样做的。他们恨你最初出现在这个城镇里。”
And I know that we cannot bring them back. Only Allah can do that.
“我知道我们无法让他们回来。只有真主能做到这一点。”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
But I hope to be able to help with the healing process.
“但我希望能帮助愈合的过程。”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
I'm also here to ensure this does not destroy the relationship we've established with people of Atha.
“我还来这里是为了确保这件事不会破坏我们与阿萨人民建立的关系。”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
I know there's a lot to do to rebuild this relationship, and this is my first step. But it's also very important that I get all the facts here. Right now I have 12 names of those who were killed and three that were wounded. So I think I'm missing one here.
“我知道要重建这种关系还有很多工作要做，这是我的第一步。但确保我获得所有事实也非常重要。目前我有12名死者和3名伤者的姓名。我想我这里少了一个。”
It just seems like such an incredibly awkward thing you're having to do.
你不得不做的这件事看起来极其尴尬。
I don't think awkward is at all the word you would use to describe something like this. It was possibly most emotional event of my life. Going out and dealing with these people in such incredible grief.
我不认为尴尬这个词能用来描述这样的事。这可能是我一生中最感性的事件。走出去与这些陷入难以置信悲痛的人打交道。
Toman.
托曼。
Akmed.
阿克梅德。
Adur.
阿杜尔。
Azisa.
阿齐萨。
Azis.
阿齐兹。
Aziseh.
阿齐泽。
What happened after that?
那之后发生了什么？
The way it works in the in the Arabic culture is, there's about a seven to ten day mourning period or grieving period after the death. So of course, I wanted to go in there. We're Americans. We want to go in. We want to fix it immediately. I wanted to go in there and make the payments to the families, and talk to them and express our regrets. So the hardest thing for me was I couldn't go into the town for seven days. So it was incredibly difficult for me.
“在阿拉伯文化中，死亡之后大约有七到十天的哀悼期。所以当然，我想进去。我们是美国人，我们想进去，想立刻解决问题。我想进去向家属付款，与他们谈话并表达我们的遗憾。所以对我来说最困难的是，我在七天内不能进那个镇子。所以这对我来说非常艰难。”
Because during those seven to ten days, you're thinking these people are deciding they hate us. And they're spreading word about how we killed these people. It's just the worst thing, from a propaganda point of view and winning over people's hearts. That's what your fear is.
“因为在那七到十天里，你一直在想，这些人决定恨我们了。他们在散布关于我们是如何杀害这些人的消息。从宣传角度和赢得人心角度来看，这真是最糟糕的事情，这是你最恐惧的。”
Well, that's part of the fear, but also I'm a human being. I'm an American. I want to get in there. And I want these people to understand that we are good people, and we're here to help them.
“嗯，那是恐惧的一部分，但我也是一个人。我是美国人。我想进去，我想让这些人明白我们是好人，我们在这里是为了帮助他们。”
Yeah.
是的。
So really, at that point, I'm sure you can hear it in my voice there. Is that I know I can't fix it. I know I can't bring them back, but I want to make it better. But out of respect, we waited seven to ten days. We went to neighboring towns and villages and told them what was going on and got the message out. And I know the message got to the people in the town.
“所以真的，在那一刻，我相信你能从我的声音里听出来。我知道我无法修复它，我知道无法让他们复活，但我希望让情况好转。出于尊重，我们等待了七到十天。我们去了邻近的城镇和村庄，告知了发生的情况并传达了信息。我知道这些消息传到了那个镇上的人耳中。”
But then the following three weeks we went in and did exactly what we were doing before-- it was eet with people, and begin to develop or rebuild relationships. And we continue to conduct operations, continued to pull bad guys out of the town.
“但在随后的三周里，我们进去做了和以前完全一样的事——就是与人们会面，开始发展或重建关系。我们继续进行行动，继续将坏人从城镇中揪出来。”
This is pretty much the standard way that he'd operated in these villages. He says, sure, there were some villages and local leaders who were sympathetic with the insurgents. But in other places, they were being bossed around by them.
这基本上就是他在这些村庄操作的标准方式。他说，确实，有一些村庄和当地领袖同情叛乱分子。但在其他地方，他们是被这些人欺负的。
A couple of terrorists who intimidated the leaders of that village could effectively control the entire village. People were scared to leave their houses. Kids stayed in the houses. Kids didn't go to school. So when you went in, and you took those guys out. And you came back and said, hey, I just caught this guy, this guy, and this guy. And I found all kinds of explosives, threat CD's, beheading CD's in their house, they're gone. They're never coming back.
“几个恐吓那个村子领袖的恐怖分子可以有效地控制整个村庄。人们害怕离开自己的房子。孩子待在家里，孩子不去上学。所以当你进去，把那些家伙抓走，回来告诉他们：嘿，我刚抓到了这个家伙，那个家伙，还有那个家伙。并且在他们的房子里发现了各种炸弹、恐吓CD、斩首CD，他们消失了。他们永远不会再回来了。”
And the most incredible thing was, you saw the change within a day. Within 24, 48 hours you would go back into that town, in a town where kids would not even wave to you or kids throw rocks at you. You'd go in the next day and they would be crowded around the humvees, just wanting to touch you or talk to you.
“最不可思议的是，你会在一天之内看到变化。在24、48小时之内，你会回到那个镇子，一个原本连孩子都不跟你挥手甚至朝你扔石头的镇子。你第二天再去，他们会挤在悍马车周围，只是想要触摸你或跟你说话。”
In Atha, he says, people waited to see who was going to win, the US-led forces or the insurgents. Until there came a turning point.
在阿萨，他说人们在等着看谁会赢，是美军还是叛乱分子。直到出现了一个转折点。
There was a distinct turning point. The turning point was when the sheik of the town came to see me. Which would never have happened before.
“有一个明显的转折点。那个转折点就是该镇的酋长来见我的时候。这在以前是永远不会发生的。”
And do you remember what he said at the beginning so as to explain? What do you remember of what he said?
你还记得他起初为了解释说了什么吗？你记得他说了些什么？
What he said was, I need your help. And that was it right there. I knew what was going to come after that.
“他说的是：我需要你的帮助。事情就是那样。我就知道接下来会发生什么。”
Just thinking about that accidental bombing, the way that it ended up working out, did that accidental bombing actually give you access to people and a way to meet with them, and a reason to meet with them that you might not have had otherwise?
仅仅想到那次意外轰炸，以及它最终带来的结果，那次意外轰炸是否真的让你获得了接近人们的方法、与他们会面的方式以及一个你原本可能没有的会面理由？
It wasn't that it gave us a reason to. We had a reason to, as we were going to be in the town, regardless. But it forced them to listen to us, because they were so hurt by the incident. And they began to understand what we were there for. And they eventually offered us forgiveness and asked for our help. And to this day, I probably have the strongest bond with that town than any other town over there.
“并不是它给了我们理由。我们原本就有理由，无论如何我们都会在那镇子上。但它迫使他们听我们说话，因为他们对那次事件感到非常伤心。他们开始理解我们来这里的目的，他们最终向我们提供了宽恕并请求我们的帮助。直到今天，我与那个城镇的联系可能比与那边的任何其他城镇都牢固。”
Captain Ryan Gist. He left the military in the Fall of 2006. He's now a law student at the University of Wisconsin. Though he still stays in touch, by email, with the Iraqis he knew in Atha.
瑞安·吉斯特上尉。他在2006年秋季退伍，现在是威斯康星大学的一名法律系学生。尽管他仍然通过电子邮件与他在阿萨认识的伊拉克人保持联系。
Act Three, The War This Time. So a couple of weeks ago, the Lancet published another study of deaths in Iraq by the same research team who did the earlier study. This time, the number of deaths that they came up with was seen as even more astounding than the first study's number. Over 650,000 extra deaths because of the war. 601,000 of those due to violence.
第三幕，这次的战争。所以几周前，《柳叶刀》发表了另一项关于伊拉克死亡人数的研究，由进行第一次研究的同一研究团队完成。这一次，他们得出的死亡数字被认为比第一次的研究数字更令人震惊。因战争导致的额外死亡人数超过65万，其中60.1万人死于暴力。
This second study got slightly more coverage than the first study. A reporter even asked President Bush about it. Our producer, Alex Blumberg, examined the debate over this new study. And he called various statisticians and epidemiologists who looked at study.
这第二项研究得到的报道比第一项稍微多了一点。一位记者甚至问了布什总统关于它的看法。我们的制片人亚历克斯·布伦伯格审视了关于这项新研究的辩论。他联系了多位审视过该研究的统计学家和流行病学家。
Well, if anything, the methodology is sounder in this study than it was in the last study. A lot of the critiques that were leveled at the last study could not be leveled at this study.
嗯，如果有的话，这项研究的方法论比上一项更严谨。上一项研究中受到的许多批评无法再套用到这项研究上。
For instance?
例如？
For instance, one of the biggest critiques of the last study was that it had a very wide confidence interval. And in this study, the confidence interval is much narrower, because they went to a lot more places. In this survey they went to 1,850 households total. And the first study, they went to only 988 households.
例如，上一项研究最大的批评之一是它的置信区间非常大。而在这一项研究中，置信区间窄得多，因为他们去了更多的地方。在这项调查中，他们总共走访了1850户人家。第一次研究只走访了988户人家。
So the critiques that you've seen of this study, are there criticisms of this study or questions about this study that seem particularly compelling though?
那么在你所见过的针对这项研究的批评中，是否有看起来特别令人信服的质疑或问题呢？
Everybody I talk to said that if you're doing this in a lab, you would do it differently. But almost everybody agreed that given that they were doing this in a war zone, the methodology was as sound as it could possibly be. And it's hard to imagine that any sort of bias that crept into the methodology could have accounted for a several hundred thousand person overcount.
我交谈过的每个人都说，如果是在实验室里做这件事，做法会有所不同。但几乎所有人都同意，考虑到他们是在战区进行这项研究，该方法论已尽可能严谨。而且很难想象，方法论中混入的任何偏差会导致数十万人的统计误差。
The fact of the number is so shocking to people who know about this stuff, that that's been the basis of criticism. And from groups that you would think would be sort of aligned with the Lancet's results. In other words, this group called Iraq Body Count. This is a group that's basically trying to do the same thing that these researchers are doing.
对于了解此事的人来说，这个数字本身就令人震惊，而这也成为了批评的基础。甚至来自那些你认为其立场与《柳叶刀》研究结果一致的团体。换句话说，这个名为“伊拉克尸体计数”的组织，基本上也在做着与这些研究人员相同的事情。
Since the beginning of the war, they've been documenting every news report of where civilians are reported killed. And they've been keeping a running tally. And then, as the war progressed, and as they got more sophisticated, they started incorporating Baghdad morgue data into their into their tallies. And they've also started keeping hospital records. And the number they have on their website is around 50,000 civilians dead.
自战争开始以来，他们就一直在记录每一条有关平民死亡报道的新闻，并持续进行统计。随着战争的推进，他们的方法也愈发成熟，开始将巴格达太平间的数据纳入统计范围，同时也开始保存医院记录。目前他们网站上显示的数据是约有5万名平民死亡。
That's their computation based on these methods.
那是他们基于这些方法得出的计算结果。
Based on these methods. Right, exactly. Which is less than a tenth of what this Lancet survey is saying they came up with. And they admit that they're doing an undercount. They admit that not every death is reported in the press, and that there's problems with the morgue reporting. So they know that they're under, but they don't think they're under by this much. So they came out with a detailed response on their website, and it's very compelling to look at.
基于这些方法。没错，确实如此。这还不到《柳叶刀》调查结果的十分之一。他们也承认自己存在漏报的情况。他们承认并非每起死亡事件都有媒体报道，而且太平间的上报工作也存在问题。所以他们知道数据偏低，但他们认为差距没那么大。因此，他们在网站上发布了详细的回应，非常值得一看。
For instance.
例如。
So one of the things that they do is they dig into the data. And so, they sort of go into the Lancet study and they say, on average, in the first half of 2006, according to the Lancet , 1,000 Iraqis have been violently killed every single day. With less than a tenth of them being noticed by any public surveillance mechanisms.
所以他们所做的事情之一就是深入挖掘数据。他们查阅了《柳叶刀》的研究，并指出，根据该研究，在2006年上半年，平均每天有1000名伊拉克人死于暴力，而其中不到十分之一被任何公共监测机制所记录。
They're not showing up in the morgue. They're not showing up in the press. Nothing.
太平间没有他们的记录。媒体也没有相关报道。什么都没有。
They're not showing up in the morgue. Or they're not being reported by the morgue. They're not being reported by the Ministry of Health. They're not being documented in press accounts.
他们没有出现在太平间里。或者说太平间没有上报他们。卫生部也没有上报他们。媒体报道中也没有记录他们。
Right.
对。
And then they sort of go on further, because the Lancet breaks down how people die. Of gunshot wounds, which they say that's very likely. It's very possible that you could miss a lot of the gunshot wounds, if somebody is being killed execution style and dumped in a river somewhere, maybe they never show up. But there's a certain percentage who are dying of car bombs. And what they say is, car bombs people notice. And that gets reported in the press. But even according to Lancet figures, if you extrapolate, even the car bomb figures aren't showing up.
接着他们又深入分析了下去，因为《柳叶刀》详细阐述了人们死亡的方式。关于枪伤，他们表示这非常有可能是遗漏统计的对象。如果有人被以行刑方式杀害并抛尸河中，可能根本就不会被记录在案。但还有一定比例的人是死于汽车炸弹袭击。他们指出，汽车炸弹袭击人们是会注意到的，新闻媒体也会进行报道。然而，即使根据《柳叶刀》的数据进行推算，连汽车炸弹袭击的伤亡人数也未能完全体现出来。
In other words, if the Lancet study is right. We should be seeing a lot more car bombs in the news and we're just not.
换句话说，如果《柳叶刀》的研究是正确的，我们应该在新闻中看到更多的汽车炸弹袭击，但事实并非如此。
And we're just not. Right. And so that's one thing. And then the second thing they say is that there should be a lot more wounded people. Because in modern wars, for every person that's killed, there is at least three that are wounded seriously.
而我们并没有。没错。所以这是一点。其次他们说，应该有更多的人受伤。因为在现代战争中，每阵亡一个人，至少会有三个人受重伤。
That's kind of a general rule of thumb.
这算是一个大致的经验法则。
That's a general rule of thumb based on lots of lots of studies of wars. So for every death-- so if there's 600,000 deaths, there should be some much greater number of wounded people who are showing up. And they do some sort of rough calculations. And they conclude that conservatively, if there are 600,000 people being killed by violence, there should be at least 800,000 people seriously wounded. But if you look at the hospital records all across Iraq, you don't see 800,000 people as having been treated for shrapnel wounds and legs getting blown off and all the things that you would expect to find for this level of violence.
这是一个基于大量战争研究得出的普遍经验法则。因此，对于每一次死亡——也就是说，如果有60万起死亡事件，那么应该会有更多数量的受伤人员出现。他们进行了一些粗略的计算，并得出结论：保守估计，如果有60万人死于暴力，那么至少应该有80万人受重伤。但如果你查看伊拉克各地的医院记录，你并不会看到有80万人因弹片伤、断肢以及在这一暴力水平下本应出现的各种创伤而接受过治疗。
And did anybody who you talked to have any explanation for how these numbers could be so high?
你交谈过的任何人是否对这些数字为何如此之高给出过解释？
Well, there's two possibilities. One is that Iraq Body Count has more faith in the reporting mechanisms currently existing in Iraq than they should. And that, in fact, even though it's hard to believe that 800,000 people are showing up at hospitals and that's not getting documented, it might be.
嗯，有两种可能。一种是“伊拉克尸体计数”组织对伊拉克目前现有的报道机制比他们应有的更信任。事实上，尽管很难相信有80万人去过医院却没被记录下来，但这确实是有可能的。
The other possibility is that the data is wrong. Either people lied to them and told them that people in their household had died, and then somehow fabricated death certificates to support that. That seems impossible. Because they were randomly selected. So it's impossible that that happened. Or the surveyors themselves concocted data. Said that people died in these households when, in fact, they hadn't.
另一种可能性是数据有误。要么是人们对调查人员撒谎，谎称家里有人去世，然后不知怎么伪造了死亡证明来支持这种说法。这似乎是不可能的，因为他们是随机抽选的。所以这种情况不可能发生。要么就是调查人员自己捏造了数据，谎称这些家庭中有人去世，而实际上并没有。
I don't think that happened. I think that would be such a huge conspiracy and such a cover up. And such a risky thing for all these people to do. Because Les was involved-- Les, the guy in the story-- was involved in both of these studies. And he did go there, and he did risk his life.
我不认为那是真的。我觉得那将是一场巨大的阴谋和掩盖，对所有这些人来说也是一件风险极大的事。因为莱斯牵涉其中——故事里的那个家伙——他参与了这两项研究。他确实去了那里，也确实冒了生命危险。
Right. If you're going to make up stuff, why go door to door in dangerous areas? Why not just sit in your office and make up stuff? And if you're going to go door to door, why not just get the data?
对，如果你要制造假数据，为什么要冒着生命危险挨家挨户去危险区域？为什么不坐在办公室里造假呢？如果你要挨家挨户走，为什么不直接拿真实数据？
Right. And if you're going to make up stuff, why make up a number that even the people who are on your alleged side are going to argue with you about? That doesn't make any sense at all. If he was going to fake the data, he would have said, there was 300,000 dead. And then everybody would have been joining in and saying, this is a horrible thing.
没错。如果你要造假，为什么编造一个连你所谓的“盟友”都要跟你争论的数字？这完全没道理。如果他要篡改数据，他会说有30万人死亡，然后所有人都会加入进来并说：这是一件可怕的事情。
Right.
没错。
And instead, he comes up with this much larger number. It just doesn't make any sense.
相反，他给出了一个大得多的数字。这简直没道理。
So if you're going to lie, do a better job.
所以如果你要撒谎，那就撒得高明点。
If you're going to lie, make it a more plausible lie.
如果你要撒谎，让谎言更令人信服。
Alex Blumberg. Special thanks today to Jerome McDonnell and WBEZ's show Worldview , where you first heard Les Roberts. Thanks Ben Shapiro and Beth Osborne Daponte, Fred Caplan and Michael White, Nancy Yousef. Laura Poitras, who has a new documentary about Iraq coming out called, My Country, My Country . Jamie Tarabay, Adam Davidson, and people at War News Radio, including Wren Elhai. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. This American Life is made possible by Volkswagen of America and the Volkswagen Jetta, encouraging listeners to stop stereotyping. Learn more at thejettareport.com.
亚历克斯·布伦伯格。今天特别感谢杰罗姆·麦克唐纳和WBEZ的节目《世界视野》，您在那里第一次听到了莱斯·罗伯茨。感谢本·夏皮罗、贝丝·奥斯本·达庞特、弗雷德·卡普兰、迈克尔·怀特、南希·尤塞夫。劳拉·波特拉斯，她有一部关于伊拉克的新纪录片即将上映，名为《我的国家，我的国家》。杰米·塔拉贝、亚当·戴维森，以及《战争新闻广播》的工作人员，包括瑞恩·埃尔海。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。《美国生活》由大众汽车美国公司和大众捷达赞助，鼓励听众停止刻板印象。在thejettareport.com了解更多。
Support for our podcast, our free podcast, comes from audible.com, where you can download audio books, magazines, newspapers, and radio shows, including archives from the last ten years of This American Life . Available at audible.com/thisamericanlife or at the iTunes store.
我们免费播客的支持来自audible.com，您可以在那里下载有声读物、杂志、报纸和广播节目，包括《美国生活》过去十年的档案。请访问audible.com/thisamericanlife或iTunes商店。
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia. Whenever he finishes a budget or correctly orders a lunch, he calls me into his office, leans back in his chair--
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。每当他完成预算或正确地订了一份午餐，他就会把我叫进办公室，靠在椅子上——
And he looks at me and he says, "Whoever did this was a very smart man."
然后他看着我说：“干这件事的人肯定是个非常聪明的人。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到这里，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。